is 64 gigabytes a complete waste of  money for the new m1 max macbook pros  now in front of me you see a 16 inch and  a 14 inch macbook pro but the difference  is 32 gigs for the 16 inch 64 for the  base i have 10 tabs open here in safari  and 20 more tabs in chrome and the next  i'm going to do is open up adobe  photoshop and open up 10 42 megapixel  raw images we're going to open up adobe  lightroom 50 raw images the performance  is basically the same so far and we are  exporting next we're gonna run xcode  open up party tug and now i'm opening up  our memory test and open a crazy video  project exported in 8 minutes and 52  seconds launch windows 11 56 gigs filled  on the 64 gig no swap and then 28 on the  32 gig model with 7.6 gig swap for 99.9  percent of us 32 gigs is performing  insanely well